I think that had operational resiliency
been around at the time of my husband's
death things could have been completely
different the bond of that Brotherhood
it it would have completely taken him
out of this element of feeling like he
was alone my name is Danica Thomas I'm
an ambassador for the independent and
fun my husband and I met um before his
third combat deployment to Afghanistan
and he was a just huge presence in the
world he uh he his smile would light up
a room when he deployed to Afghanistan
in
2009 they had a very very rough
deployment in March of 2010 he was hit a
suicide bomber blew up and it the the
vest the svest detonated and the ball
bearings from the vest blew through my
husband's chest essentially taking out
his entire respiratory system he did
survive his injuries but we had a long
road home we welcomed him at Walter Reed
and spent about six months up there
doing rehab and transition down to Fort
Brag whereare he would then medically
retire about a year after his retirement
after seeking help um through the VA and
um private sector he um had what
clinicians later described as a
flashback he ended up clearing a home in
our residential neighborhood killing two
people a dog and then turning the gun on
himself
so since then my daughters and I um who
were at the time two and a half and six
months old have devoted Our Lives to
trying to make other families never have
to experience what we have
to operation resiliency is a program
within the independence fund that
reunites heavy hit combat teams back
together for connectivity Brotherhood
Sisterhood working on resiliency skills
and tools to be able to go back into
transition or civilian life and have the
type of bond that they need in order to
like work on mental health and SU
prevention so operation resiliency was
born at a funeral uh one that we never
should have had it started at my late
husband's funeral and at that funeral we
saw that hundreds of paratroopers
deployed from all all parts of the
country to come together to say their
final goodbye to their fellow brother
and years later when we buried another
one of the Bravo Company members uh the
CEO Sarah verado heard someone say I'll
see you at the next one and at that
point she needed to be sure that we
weren't going to see each other at the
next funeral and so this Innovative
outof the-box solution uh to help with a
problem that's plaguing our veteran
Community um
[Music]
suicide
opz is really about recognizing that
even the toughest among all of us still
need support I'm Jason murf I'm the
owner and founder of Grill your bleep
off so Grill your bleep off is a Texas
made veteran owned uh gourmet food
company is what we're really merged into
food always brings everyone together no
matter race religion politics you throw
down an amazing plate of food everyone's
going to sit down enjoy each other's
time um and with that being said that's
what we always fall back to so whenever
I met Sarah and her team over at the
Independence fund it was just kind of
like seeing the amazing work that these
people are doing bringing people
together especially with operation
resiliency it was just like there's no
better you know match as soon as we saw
everything that they had going on it was
just like yes I want to be able to
support and help out however we can by
contributing to operation resiliency
we're helping veterans that are able to
attend a 4-day retreat that's free of
charge um where they're gaining tools to
hand Le um all life's pressures um it's
about acknowledging that it's okay to
not be okay and that's you know at the
end of the day a message that we
wholeheartedly endorse my urge is that
people talk about operation resiliency
and the the change that it has put
forward